a local woman is grieving tonight after
her husband set fire to their home and
took his own life she and her four
children are now without a place to live
tonight victoria saha takes a look at
how suicide impacts those left behind
and the options available for those
suffering he's a really funny guy cora
williams is remembering her husband
jerome williams of 11 years the
childhood sweethearts share four
children together he really loved his
children so much he really did which is
why cora never thought her family would
ever be living this nightmare on july 7
cora got a chilling text from jerome
showing a picture of their house on fire
and then he texted
that this was the last time i'd hear
from him
he told me
to tell the kids that he loved them and
that he was sorry but it was too late
the family says jerome had set their
house on fire then took his own life i
just don't think he was really in his
right
mindset cora tells me it was only after
her husband's passing that she found out
he was diagnosed with bipolar depression
when he was younger but never got help
for it i knew that he did struggle
but i think he really was more like
ashamed and
didn't want to seek the help a problem
brewing for many people suffering from
mental illness according to karen
esposito a psychiatrist with roseman
university people who are dealing with
mental health issues
can
reach a moment of crisis really at any
time which is why the new suicide
hotline number 988 is so crucial giving
someone the chance to talk it out the
most important thing is to have someone
to listen to in the moment to give some
thoughts and guidance and direction as
for cora she hopes her story can be a
turning point for those suffering in
silence but for right now the mama 4 is
trying to push forward
one day at a time i just feel like i'm
trying to survive each day victoria zaha
live local now
again if you or someone you know is
experiencing suicidal thoughts call 988
that is the new three-digit number for
the suicide and crisis lifeline and as
for the williams family a gofundme has
been set up to help them we have that
link on our website eightnewsnow.com